oi meu nome é isabel eu tenho 10 anos
está no 5º ano
hoje eu vim falar sobre um entendimento
global
eu escolhi esse tema porque só nesse ano
nós já presenciamos dois atos
terroristas em paris na flórida
além disso eu também escolheu esse tema
porque descobri que 2016 é no
entendimento global existe hoje muito
desentendimento no mundo como brigas
guerras discussão e indiferenças as
pessoas se desentendem por diversos
motivos como por exemplo brigas no
futebol
bullying em religião e política
as conseqüências desses desentendimentos
podem ser morte sofrimento tristeza e
assassinatos
nós podemos fazer muitas coisas para
melhorar essa situação como ser amigo de
pessoas de diferentes religiões
respeitar pessoas de diferentes cores e
raças e conversar e chegar a um
entendimento
existem ações que também podem ser
adotadas no nosso dia a dia como evitar
brigas no trânsito e respeitar as
pessoas
o mundo precisa de taiz então se você
quer ajudar a transformar o mundo olha
agora eo lugar é aqui
obrigada